but I think Darius by either K or
submission this thing's not going five
rounds and you would have to give
Daniels a title shot what are we doing
here you have to look at his resume dude
he's won one two three four five six
seven eight this be his ninth win in a
row if you beat Charles Oliver
especially against the Finish there is
no Rhyme or Reason why he doesn't fight
for a title
what's popping fam June 5th Monday
morning June Gloom here in Los Angeles
and we are feeling it it's that chilly
out there fam hope you guys are doing
well how's the kids summer break coming
up parents figure it out kissing me on
the loose gotta entertain those little
bastard 24 7. he's got stuff to figure
out as parents our summer breaks are
different aren't they fam aren't they
Fresh Off The a long car ride from San
Diego I was in La Jolla this weekend The
Comedy Store one of my favorite venues
thanks for everybody that came out
Sunday show never ever have I done a
Sunday show and uh it was fun different
different vibe that the energy of the
crowds is different on a Sunday but uh
Friday and Saturday was so much fun
thanks for everybody it came out a lot
of support in San Diego our boy madaree
Ariza came out the punt god
um hopefully has some news as far as a
team goes that's his story to tell him
not mine but if he did go this team I
want him to go to it would make my year
and I'd be the first one to buy his
jersey what I'd do is just one of those
custom jerseys you know before they
release his I just make my custom one uh
because I'm a big time punt God guy
um so shout out to him our boy Remy the
Navy SEAL from firing the kid came to
the show with his beautiful wife the
boys from buttery Bros came all the
buttery Bros they flew in Sunday at six
the show's at seven they jetted over
from the airport so shout out to The
Buttery Bros absolutely love those dudes
uh chin came chin maker made a an
appearance
and then uh my feature was Brett Forte
who's a comic out of Canada he's banned
from Canadian TV he's such a Savage uh
that he's a monster he did so well man
and then uh Adam tiller I met Adam when
I was at the Tacoma Comedy Club he's uh
he's based out of there he's based out
Tacoma Seattle area but he's a Savage
too so it was a good you were there chin
yeah monsters right yeah Monsters the
crowd's rocking that my favorite club
man I could live in La Jolla
it is beautiful over there yeah it's
like you know everyone's like oh we're
gonna are you moving to Nashville moving
to Florida you're moving to Texas I'm
like
San Diego could be a good spot
it's not awoke like it is here you know
it could be a good spot man took the
fellas to the Padres game on uh Sunday
went to the public game on Sunday's
military appreciation day this is the
most fire Jersey in all of uh
professional sports I think when they do
the military jerseys so I had to go
there and pick myself up to the
authentic military jersey
what bothered me is they sell this one
it's the only one I could get and then
the the team wore the green camo the
jungle camo
are you gonna sell me the one they're
not wearing you look like an [__]
um what can you do I mean Jay picked up
those fear of God San Diego hats you can
only get those at the arena so we're
pretty crunk and uh that's Brad Forte on
the left there you think it's uh Zac
Efron but that is uh not he's a handsome
bastard yeah great kid great freaking
kid so uh shout out to uh San Diego man
absolutely love it down there and
everybody who came out appreciate you
guys I'll be doing spots around La for
the next few weeks so excited to be home
with the kiddos
his baseball camp starting he has all
sorts of crap going on for the summer
keeping those little bastards busy
trying my best man trying my best uh we
do have a cow bass fight campaigning
this Saturday for UFC 289. uh I will
almost guarantee you the Cowboys fight
campaign will be more exciting than this
pay-per-view of UFC 289 and will cost
you nothing so if you'd rather just
listen to us watch this terrible
pay-per-view that's probably the move
I'm not going to sugarcoat it this is
one of the worst papers we've had in a
long time
this isn't any disrespect to the
fighters on the card when I talk like
that it's a disrespect to the UFC for
putting this card on this is not a
typical pay-per-view especially in
Canada usually they load Canada dates up
uh this one is very soft they they're
thinking they're lucky fight stars that
Charles Oliveira and derush had to
reschedule and they were the co-main
event if you don't have Charles Oliveira
and Darius on this card you do not have
a card that you could charge anybody for
now the Canadians they they love
fighting so they're going to sell this
bad boy out no matter what but my God
the disrespect to the Canadian fans come
on dude come on man give us something
here now to be fair I get it it's tough
you know schedules have to line up stuff
like that and they've announced some big
ass fights so I'm grateful you know I
watch everything I'm grateful
um and they do have I think they have a
paper like the next four months was it
two in July there's one June two in July
there's a big one in August really big
one August the massive ones in July big
one in August and they also have Nate
Diaz Jake Paul in August and there's a
lot of boxing going on too I know you
guys aren't the biggest boxing fans but
you have Crawford's uh Spence coming up
which is massive I mean best fight in
boxing in a hot second
um do you want Davis can be out for a
little bit he's fighting with the
inmates in prison right now that's all
right it's all good it's all good we'll
figure it out but um yeah it's again I'm
not crapping on this card I'm not
trashing the card but to charge 79.99
this is a tough sell I'm like a
sugarcoat to you guys tough sell very
tough very tough watch fighting for free
how about that enjoy yeah enjoy we had a
great lineup and announce everybody uh
coming up here pretty soon
um yeah man
you know as far as fight World goes the
fights over the weekend the two big
Headliners from the fight night uh kind
of the stars of that card obviously you
have the the controversial decision with
Kai Kara France and uh our mayor albazi
um and then you also have Jim Miller I'd
say three stars you have Jim Miller
knocked a dude out in 23 seconds
just put him in the Hall of Fame right
now can you guys do that also I think
Jim Miller there's like the Jim Miller
rise right now you get the matte Brown
It's Like These Old heads doing the damn
thing if you look at like guys who could
compete in the top 10 Jim Miller looks
like one of those guys to knock a dude
out in Jesse Butler a young Prospect out
in 23 seconds I think it's time we can
start putting that guy in some big time
fights it's Jim Miller for God's sakes
dude Jim Miller Jim Miller against
anybody how how is he not on paper for
you you tell me Jim Miller against
anybody including Jesse Butler's not
bigger than uh damn near every card on
this pay-per-view coming up besides the
main event coming event might be bigger
than the main event let's be honest here
right
um and then Tim Elliott name one person
in America probably the world that
wasn't rooting for Tim Elliott after
going through find out his wife was
cheating on him with his coach I mean
everyone's rooting for that guy now did
Tim Elliott look fantastic no but for
Tim Elliott to deal with all that crap
and still be able to go in there and
execute a winning uh performance hats
off to him I can't imagine what he's
doing with Bentley so shout out to him
my boy Andre olowski got finished
put him in the Hall of Fame right now as
well
um so that one was tough but that's in
regards to the big controversy is the
Amir and kaikira France uh decision
Split Decision
again how many times if when you guys
listen to me talk on the show is it
about the judging the judges or thing
judging is the biggest problem in mixed
martial arts across the board
we can't change the judges the judges
are who they are it is what it is I
think we need to allocate more resources
to them whether it's
um we just have to set them up for more
success what doesn't work for me is
given these outs of going toughest job
and fighting man stuff stop with that
you know and the criteria the scoring
criteria the must system there's so many
issues with it there's so many little
tweaks that we could make which would
give the fighters a better advantage to
go you can't leave the hands of the
judges what the hell are you talking
about man
how many times I told you this can't
even the hands of Judges hey it turns
out a mayor Al bazzi and kaikoura France
they're both pretty freaking good dude
it's very tough at flyweight to get a
finish so we should be able to rely on
the judges I the only time the only time
you're going to get a change is when
Dana White's had enough but today and
why he's putting out other fires you
know he's dealing with other business or
he's just like we're just making money
we don't give a [__] about the judging
because trust me if it became such a
problem which it is but to him he's not
since not a fighter it became such an
issue where they started losing money
trust me you'd have a changing judging
by next week you have a change in
judging by this Saturday UFC 289. it's
just not it's not affecting his bottom
line so we're gonna put up with it
you're gonna take the fights they give
you you're gonna shut the [__] up you're
gonna take the Judgment that they give
you and you can do nothing about it
you'll do nothing Jon Snow you can do
nothing about it You Know Nothing Jon
Snow we all just got to eat crow We Just
Gotta Eat This Big black dick that's how
it goes no one's gonna do [__] No One's
Gonna Do Anything we're just gonna
complain for a day and move on that's
how this goes uh I thought it was pretty
clear kite care of France won one rounds
one uh one four and five Clara's day
um could even give him rounds one two
four and five three definitely win but
one two four and five I would assume was
the judging but for sure I thought even
Ray Charles would give him one four and
five
close day but it is what it is
you know what are you gonna do yeah
let's take a little break kids talking
about all the Real Housewives of the
fight world because UFC 289 is sure to
pack a punch download the DraftKings
Sportsbook app right now use code shop
show new customers can make a five
dollar UFC 289 bet and score 200 in
bonus bets instantly there's some good
dogs on here in the main event you got
Irene aldana fighting Amanda Nunes she's
a dog I like the Mexican get it done and
add to the titles for all the Mexicans
out there the Mexicanos good luck out
there you got Charles Charles Oliveira
banil Darius Darius is a slight favorite
but he's a good one to bet on
um Dan ige is a big favorite so you
could parlay Dan ige guitar Anders in
there that's a tough one
um and then you got uh Darius and aldana
or if you just want to bet on the
straight up dog now Dana that's probably
your safest bet uh but do it with my
friends at draftking Sportsbook right
now promo code is shop show only at
draftking Sportsbook gambling problem
call Wayne Hunter Gambler in
Massachusetts call
800-327-5050 or visit gambling uh
gamblinghelplinema.org in New York call
8778 Hope NY or text Hope NY
467-369 in Kansas call
1-800-522-4700 on behalf of Boot Hill
Casino Resort Kansas in West Virginia
gambling problem calling her Gambler or
visit
www.1800 gambler.net all games regulated
by West Virginia Lottery please please
play responsibly uh in partnership with
Hollywood Casino at Charlestown Races in
Connecticut help is available for
problem gambling call
887-89-777 or visit
ccpg.org 21 or older in most eligible
States but age varies by jurisdiction
see draftkings.com Sportsbook for
details and state-specific responsible
gambling resources bonus bet expires
seven days after Assurance eligibility
and deposit restrictions apply terms and
at sportsbook.draft kings.com MMA terms
if you're still listing all you got to
do is BET on UFC 289 use my friends at
DraftKings promo code shop show you're
welcome and just to uh double check us
888-789-777
yeah he said two eights all right
obviously Izzy went off on the judges
yeah it's his boy man he said he he
predicted it during this room I guess
the two particular judges I forgot their
name you gotta assume they're gonna
screw yeah and those Fighters fighting
uh this weekend Vancouver trust me I
beat andrelowsky I mean everybody lost
that fight the fans lost was an exciting
fight I beat him they screwed me over a
split decision so those those Fighters
fighting this weekend Get Ready Get
Ready Get ready man but that's what it
is but
you got a pay-per-view this freaking
weekend UFC 289 is going down like I
said I'm not gonna [__] you guys
it's not gonna knock your hair back
um now also to the UFC's defense
whenever we do assume the card's gonna
be bad it tends to be some of the best
cards of the Year sometimes
I just don't see it with this one but
again there's a reason why when
everyone's like oh this card's trash the
fighters hear this stuff and they put on
they really show out so let's hope
that's the case here look at the
matchups you can have some snooze fast
uh that Mark Andre uh Barry Holt and uh
Erica Anders
just stylistically to kick off the main
card that's probably going to the
decision
uh Danny gay Nate uh landwair Nate land
where it's exciting as [__] fighting
again fighting a guy in Dan ea uh I soon
dance the favorite here
you look at the strength of schedule
Dan's gone through he only loses the tip
of the spare guys anytime he knocks him
down a level he starches dudes now I'm
not saying that Nate's down a level but
compared to the guys danier's lawsuit
you'd be on that second tear it's not a
first tier guy he's exciting we love him
I will always watch Nate fights no you
know knock against Nate but it his how
should I say this his fundamentals when
it comes to boxing he's not as smooth as
Danny gay when when the house is on fire
Dan AAA stays pretty calm cool and
collecting can execute and get
combinations off I think he knocks out
Nate NATO Wild Boy NATO my favorite
fighter to watch but that comes with a
you know with a little asterisk there
fun but when it comes to Danny yay who's
you know pretty versed in boxing uptake
Danny gay all day this probably weighs a
minus 260 favorite
um
yeah you know that Danny gay one has a
chance to get a finish uh the Mallot
fugit fight fugit [__] it [__] like
[__] [__] it [__] it
um you know this Canadian thing it is
what it is
um and then to the co-main event which
is by far the best fight on the card
Charles Oliveira uh benil Darius I'm a
Darius fan I don't know what it is I
have nothing against Charles Oliver he's
one of the greatest fighters of all time
first battle Hall of Famer when the best
ever do it I keep picking against them
this can be no different I don't know
what to tell you guys I'm sorry sorry
Dario she's my guy I think Darius gets
this done I could see him uh clipping
them deer hits harder but also
you'll notice Charles Olivera even the
mark Chef fight uh the Michael Chandler
fight which you end up winning my
channel fight but Charles de Lavera will
get hit
Dario shit's like a [__] Mack truck
he's very versed in uh kickboxing his
hands are heavy he has a granite chin
but the difference is here and this is
why I'm picking Darius Oliveira get hit
and the guys he's fought before because
Charles de levere is such you know he's
the best submission artist we've had in
the UFC with as far as performance bonus
and finishes go so guys are aware of
that in the the Rock'em he gets sat down
on his ass then they're scared to go in
and finish him
Darius is a high-level black belt he is
not scared of Charles Oliver's guard I
guarantee you so he's going to hit him
and he's going to not be scared to go
down and finish him so I think Jerry
gets the Finish there I could even see
Darius getting a submission
but I think Darius by either KO or
submission this thing's not going five
rounds and you would have to give Darius
a title shot wait what are we doing here
you have to the judges you do nothing
about fine whatever I'm gonna eat that
dick but when it comes to giving Dairy
shata shot we have got to give him Top
Shot after this look at his resume dude
he's on one two three four five six
seven eight this being his ninth win in
a row if you beat Charles Oliver
especially if he gets to finish and
Charles Oliver was the king of the
lightweight Division and it's not like
this is an old weather Charles Olivera
y'all must have forgot yeah the guy lost
on Mark Jeff yeah damn near impossible
beat Mike Chev right now nope it's gonna
be tough not just me reigning champ for
a long time there used to different
matchup form which we'll get into that
after this but before that you'd be
Justin gaichi Dustin Porey ever heard of
him Michael Chandler ever heard of him
Tony Ferguson ever heard of him Kevin
Lee ever heard of him Jared Gordon ever
heard of him Nick Lance Jim Miller
he submitted Jim Miller you son of a
[__] chin a little respecter dude this
dude has performed the knights across
the board his last loss was in 2017
before the mock Jeff title loss but
before that his last loss was in 2017
against Paul Felder
you almost forgot Paul Felder too he
used to be a Savage you see him doing
the Compton looking all cute in his suit
a [__] Savage
let's just run 200 miles too for the
[__] of it don't give a [__]
so you know with that being said
my point of going through Charles
Oliveira's resume is if Darius beats him
which he will and he gets a finish there
is no Rhyme or Reason why he doesn't
fight for a title you gotta be [__] me
dude and Mark Chef Darius is a [__]
scrap dude again stylistically dare you
she poses a lot of problems for marketev
now is he gonna be a favorite of that
fight no but he has the capability on
the feet to finish him and he's also no
joke on the ground he's also tough to
take down you know so there's a lot of
there's some differences there big
differences so I I like darius's chances
especially in this fight and against
mock Jeff not a bad dog either in that
fight and then with the main event
Amanda Nunes Irene aldana
um
Mexicans are doing the damn thing
Mexicans are I don't know if you guys
are noticing they're taking over the UFC
it was dakistanians for a little bit and
Russians right now to Mexicans Mexicans
doing the damn thing so there's
something to it with these Mexicans this
is a much much tougher matchup for
Amanda Nunes I would say most people in
our space that do what I do or the
analysts or experts quote unquote are
picking against Amanda Nunes there's a
reason for that there's something
special going on with the Mexicans her
boxing sure take down defense is pretty
good if I compare her to the herd of the
Jordan gerandamy fight you know with
your enemy she was such a elite Striker
a man who has had to take her down
um aldana's takedown defense is much
much uh better than uh geronomy so I I
can see why people are picking her I'm
gonna go ahead and pick her because if I
pick against the Maxi when I go home
because his issues so I'm taking the
Mexican here and the Mexicans can be
reigning Champs all over the goddamn
place you got a lot of Mexican Champions
right now
um so for Amanda news also Amanda Nunez
35 the bantamweight cuts a lot for her
she'd rather fight at 45
um
so I would assume she's the greatest of
all time hands down but I I would assume
a lot of the Native white people are
picking against her she's 35 the weight
cut we've heard Rumblings she's her
heart's not really in it you know so
she's set up to lose this fight to be
honest with you
shut up lose this fight so we'll see man
I just want a good fight good finish I
don't give a [__] who wins to be honest
with you
completely transparent there
so far Amanda is a minus 325 on
DraftKings I like the dog there I like
the dog and Darius he's he started out
as a favorite still the favorite
um yeah
interesting
so see you never know what's going on
but again when we say oh these cards are
sleepers and the the fighters share this
and they show out man you know yeah I'm
sure Dana before after the Wayans he
does this big like rah-rah speech and
he's gonna let him know hey people think
this is gonna be a [__] card it's up to
you guys fighter show out so usually
we're gonna get a good product my the
only caveat there is when you look at
the stylistic matchups it I don't know
unless guys say [__] it let's trade you
know to make it exciting but stylishly
across the board just not good fights
it's not that these aren't great
Fighters just their opponents the Styles
it doesn't make for exciting matchups it
is what it is
so you know but really the only reason
you're paying 80 is going to be a
degenerate like me the reason paying 80
is for Charles Oliver dear use I'd pay
80 if it was like Hey one fight
basically what boxing does they're doing
what boxing does here they put a big
name at the top the rest of the card
like I guess I'll put up with it
but hopefully they're fun we'll see
let's take a little break fam cow bass
fight Japan UFC 289 is this Saturday 7
P.M Pacific on thick boy YouTube we got
Paulie Shore the Schmo and a very
special guest going down for UFC 289 so
tune in live 7 P.M Pacific on thick boy
YouTube gentlemen are you ready to take
your skin care to the next level I know
I am with Father's Day your dad's face
looks like crap so guess what help them
out seize the opportunity so your dad
can give his face all juicy our trusted
Partners at Caldera lab the leaders in
men's skin care have the tools to
improve the skin of the father figures
in your life all right uh does your dad
look like Clint Eastwood let's get that
juicy face pop in with their clinically
proven products wrinkle free fine lines
and signs of aging are visible reduced
and a Surefire boost to their confidence
this summer join Caldera lab for the
skin care upgrade trust by countless
Bros use code shop at Cal daredlab.com
that's
c-a-l-d-e-r-a-l-a-b.com to enjoy
exclusive 20 off their finest products
they gave your boy the eye cream and I
use it every freaking day it feels so
good on my face all right it got great
products for the Bros out there get your
confidence up in your face get rid of
those crow's feet get rid of get rid of
those nuts hanging underneath your eyes
get 20 off with the code shop at
calderilab.com that's
c-a-l-d-e-r-a-lab.com that's 20 off at
Cal Caldera lab.com by promo code shop
make Father Time a thing of the past
this summer with the best skin care
tools from Caldera lab enjoy because
this episode of the shop show breakdown
you'll see 289 which you have the Cal
bats if I keep paying for it 7 PM
Pacific live on thick boy YouTube with
Paulie Shore the schmoe and a very
special guest it's all going down this
Saturday 7 P.M Pacific but you know one
thing one thing is true when you're
watching them fight opinion when you're
watching this podcast and watch me do
stand up your boys on that happy hippo
Kratom it's the only company that I
trust for every show I take their little
Kratom shots the highly concentrated
Kratom shot the sour apple they have
butterscotch all right it gets you going
get you in the mood get your brain fired
up well I love it it's a basically a
turbo for my brain piece helps me get
tackle my busy schedule helps you just
get stuff done that's the best way to
describe it it's not a crazy energy
drink or some crazy espresso shot coffee
you know that stuff get a nice bounce
just get stuff done warm type of feeling
all right like I said my favorite to the
shots however you get your Kratom they
have gummies they got powders they get
the concentrate shots they have energy
shots they also have these freaking
first ever to Market K dips Kratom
extract pouches the first ever to Market
this is Wintergreen I like the blue
Razzle they're 200 milligrams per pouch
your boy used about three of them
they're are fantastic nicotine free
tobacco-free k dips first ever Kratom
dips to the market the boys at happy hip
are getting it done try them out you're
gonna love them go to happyhippo.com
promo code is thick23 you save 20 off
the K dips you save twins off the Kratom
shots the energy shots the gummies the
powders it's the best crater on the
planet take it from your boy I don't do
anything without happy hippo
happyhippo.com promo code is thick23
let's get back to the program
what do you got you
alrighty
let's start off well
we already talked about this but Izzy
went off on the judges he did this don't
worry that code is he don't wear that
big it's too big
but yeah
you put nah bro fuse in the specific
hypocrisy and salt Deez Nuts
yeah I threw that before even seeing the
scorecards because I know them too will
f it up how many times will the will
they rob athletes of their moments of
Glory their money and their livelihood
for their family F them
dunks
they need what let me get the whole one
here
uh
uh they need to expire quickly and go
Mike Bell was only judges scores
probably those two definitely need to
disappear he went hard and how did Mike
uh right here was judge or Mike Bell
almost said Mike Judge uh 10-9 yeah
that's right 9 10.
9 10. I can see I get the second round
and then ten nine four ten nine five
yeah you got it right I can see how you
give the second round to Amir but yeah
he's pretty spot on there I'm with Izzy
on this yeah I'm with Izzy
they're saying yes you can do nothing
Izzy all them you knew nothing we're
complaining about this that's all they
do I can play on the show and then we'll
forget about it and watch Ultimate
Fighter tomorrow and then watch the
Pay-Per-View on Saturday and watch
Cowboys fight campaign and you know what
you can do nothing
all you can eat dick how about that
what can they there's a big warm [__]
you can do nothing what could they do
though the fighters can't do anything
all right I don't know how's it going
though you know what I'm saying it's
like there has to be something we can do
here I don't know there has to be
something when I say we I mean the final
Fighters yeah yeah
yeah you could do what the SAG Rider's
doing you just protest but okay unless
we see you're changing and judging
nobody's fighting and what you do here's
my here's my thought fellas you rally
the troops all right you rally the
troops and you do it before the big big
big event like UFC 300 the week of hey
guess what unless there's a change we
ain't fighting
guaranteed to see some real changes
guarantee it this whole it's the
commission it's not me no Dana no no
dude you say JUMP everybody says how hot
you could make a change you just don't
have to it's not affecting your bottom
line so if the fighters go all right and
they came to us for a long pace so I
doubt they're gonna do it for the
judging but if they decided to put their
foot in the ground it'd make I guarantee
you two days you'd have a change
here's a question for you um when you're
when you're actually fighting and you
did need the money right yeah yeah and
then a bunch of Fighters like hey well
let's do this let's do the protest would
you be able to during that time when
you're hungry and you you needed money
would you do the protesters absolutely
not
oh no my money man yeah y'all crazy
because all it all it takes is one call
from day and go hey man all these guys
are being [__] you want to be the
main event hell yeah [__] these dudes
oh that's funny that's how it goes yeah
that's why so it's a tough it's tough
man I can sit here in our cozy studio
and say you guys need to do this but I
you know I'm not paying their bills a
lot of them have kids and wives and
houses and mortgages and yeah you know
car payments so it's easy for me to say
yeah but still do it it's gonna happen
then but do it but do it and then let me
know how it goes it could be a disaster
yeah
um so you already heard Dana White
saying that uh Jon Jones would no he
wasn't saying that anyways Dana White is
actually doubling down on the whole
Tyson Fury fighting in the UFC and
octagon against Jon Jones if he wants to
take it they have the money I thought he
doesn't make circus fights what happened
to those days I know it I mean it's
always one thing or another it's
yeah it's strange right so hold on let
me get this straight
the reason
the reason Francis basically left is
because they want to entertain the
Francis fight and then now you're open
to this circus act of Francis fighting
in the Octagon like James Tony's style
Tyson Tyson Fury what'd I say Francis
Francis but now you're open to
Tyson fighting in the UFC
you're gonna figure out that deal but
you can't figure out Francis and Tyson
and boxing yeah okay that tracks they
just didn't like Francis they're like
we're good we're good like if it's
coming to fruition now then also the
bummer thing to see is France is
tweeting out like hey if you want to
come get some music on the screen it's
like oh dude the video is just not there
it's just his back and he's like yeah
and even though it's not like he's
crushing it it's always you know it's
good they should say all right
anyway I'll be ready
I'm entertaining because again think
about it if you're Tyson Fury
would you want to do business with a
proven commodity and a month the best by
far the best marketing professional
sports not even close not even [__]
close by far the best Market machine the
most powerful Market machine they have
all the money you know it's gonna get
all the views possible do you want to
entertain that deal with you know and
you know you're gonna make legit money
or do you want to take a risk and go
with Francis and maybe the pfl is
involved that's not a proven commodity
in any facet uh they're not even
inboxing you know or do you just want to
deal with your boxing promoter and then
Francis and then you're you're basically
have to sell it yourself or do you want
to go over to the UFC where you know
they're gonna they're gonna sell their
side so then all you gotta do is worry
about your side which is pretty [__]
good and those two collab together we're
going Sizzler Oregon Bank on Francis
who's never been a proven commodity
never sold pay-per-views never was able
to Market really you're gonna go with
that side now to say easy this is easy
unfortunately sucks dude I hate saying
it sucks absolutely sucks
you're listening you're entertaining
this
yeah I mean you're a fight oosick right
because that's what you do for a living
is a box but sure we're gonna entertain
this
I do not see Francis fighting him in any
facet especially as the tweets I was
like oh man
he said come get some friends like this
see that's why that's why dude give me
something hot to work with you know yeah
give me something hot that's why Connor
Floyd worked Connor give you the [__]
fire dude serving up hot lasagna baby
all right I got a buddy who's uh
I get a buddy who's helping Francis out
with things as far as managing stuff
like that
he ran this idea by me hope I'm not
speaking I turned her he ran ID by me
about fighting in beer knuckle
I said if if Francis left the UFC
to fight in pfl
and bare knuckle he has lost this war
he goes no it could be good man because
their Champion is homeboy from the UFC
um Alan Belcher oh yeah wants to fight
so he was like Hey what if we did a
one-off
mpfl is cool with what if you did one
off with bkfc
just to get him active get them in the
news and for him to starch Alan Belcher
and then would and if you know if Fury
and Joshua and these guys and Wilder see
you know Francis absolutely take this
dude's head up head off does that get
them excited to fight him I go it's
tough man I don't think a nobody watches
bare knuckle for the most part as far as
the masses goes the the downloading the
app and stuff like that so you'd get
highlights
but to me it would just it would devalue
Francis and I said and there is it's
mixed martial arts and this is bare
Knuckles so you know the chance to get
knocked out even higher I said you ever
thought about this what if you were to
lose to Alan Belcher
career's over you know I can that all
those fights are over is worse than the
pfl over
that's not knocking out on Belcher
that's saying Alan Belcher is no punk
now I'm belcher's no punk it's also bare
knuckle we've seen guys who they might
be more technical they might be better
Strikers you look at Mike Perry in the
UFC not the most you know fluid best
strike we've ever seen pfl he's
starching dude bkf's yeah starching
dudes starching them you know take them
gloves off though and come get some he
beats the [__] out of These Guys
these guys who rock all this Fighters
technique-wise run circles I might pay
doesn't matter so for Alan Belcher at
scary fight for Francis so is the juice
worth the squeeze yeah it gets them
active again yeah maybe the the other
big boxers see it on the other side
though what I'm just saying have you
ever thought about what if he lost
game over you know yeah
see I'm so quiet out there
yeah I was seeing if I could hear him
like I can't hear him in the background
um so since we talked about bkfc I guess
the most recent one that they had the
pay-per-view
um they said that they blamed 734 000
illegal streams for taking away from
their streams but they still hit six
figures a little bit above six figures
I don't know how you judge it or how you
gauge that but well there's no it's the
same thing trailer always talks about
like there's no
there's no way to prove this nobody's
gonna audit this and be like prove it
there's no way yeah it's like with the
flu like trailer he says the Floyd
Connor it didn't sell out many
pay-per-views they can release so it's
the biggest pay-per-view ever really No
One's Gonna audit that no one
there's no there's no way to do it so I
don't know promoters are going to
promote I don't know you know I'd be
surprised very surprised
yeah it's because again it's not they're
not known for papers the app you gotta
download the app it's difficult I heard
it was difficult so for the general fan
there's like oh whatever yeah make it
easy for them to consume you know yeah
alrighty uh your boy Curtis blades his
next opponent is going to be that crazy
interesting Johnson I love this fight oh
you do yeah I love this fight I'm so
curious so curious what happens here
yeah
so curious I you know I still say that
what the Curtis blades that lost that
last fight I don't know what that you
know against uh our boy pavlovich to
lose that giant rush and nothing to you
know hang your head about he's a [__]
Savage but
curse blades and Almeida I mean it's
such an interesting fight because Chris
Blade's gonna have to he can't just
shoot in for the double egg right he's
gonna be we're gonna be able to see a
striking much better Striker than I'll
meet up the other thing Almeida ain't
taking Curtis blades down like he's
taking these other boys down that ain't
happening I don't think Curtis has Chris
Blade's ever been taken down that ain't
happening dude tell you that right now
so then you get here's the thing you
didn't get a really cool knockout from
Curtis blades
or you're gonna get a terrible fight
don't even lie to you guys or if we're
we're gonna be able to see Almeida if he
can transition even if he gets taken
down can you transition in the back you
just do that good for a big man we can
transition in the scramble and get to
his back because if he does he gets by
Chris blades he's going Sizzler because
after this it's only top four
it's in Brazil too so you know who
they're rooting for obviously oh yeah I
do too I've been there
I love this fight though
but this one's this is one of those ones
where it's like you didn't get a
knockout or it's gonna be a [__] show
you're gonna get Derek Lewis Francis
boring fight
no in between
yeah he's getting monsters lately Curtis
yeah that's where he's at man that's the
life you live
um here's a quick one I saw this how
happy are people at Gregory every time a
lot of people do yeah so many people get
happy I get it I get it again I don't
hate on Greg Hardy what he did with the
accused of awful [__]
the only thing I hear from people very
close to him is he's such a sponge and
he's so humble and grateful to have this
life in mixed martial arts and boxing
and he just he he listens and he's not
an [__] in training he's a great
training partner that's all here I only
hear good things now the past yeah it's
awful you know whatever happened there
but people just celebrate for obvious
reasons when the stew gets killed I
don't know what's going on but you
should probably stop
seems like it yeah so I even saw some
big NFL guys like man heart is my boy he
needs to stop man
boxing different animal boxing
completely different animal at least
take a long break after getting knocked
even if you're striking the UFC it's not
like again there's not enough hours in
the day for him to make up an experience
but what he's so athletic in the UFC he
can get by you know to a certain level
and then once you get to those even the
middle tier guys they've seen a big
athletic guy they know what a right hand
looks like they're gonna be able to
execute and get you out of there in
boxing different animal
it's not it's not going well for him
he's gonna get starched huh yeah so this
is from spinning back fist
he's so big yep
[Music]
and then
he gets a count
I like to enthusiasm of the announcers
the head movement of his opponent's no
punk man
hard looks giant too he he's like 300
pounds dude
his punches don't look good do they
would you say Hardy's punches they don't
look good though no it's all arm
punching let's not use his hips he's
also tired
you know yeah
I know nothing about the guy either but
I assume he's not a world beater though
you know so for Hardy you don't have
enough money's in this your want to keep
going but it's a bummer I hate to see it
I hate to see it all right so Nate Diaz
posted this recently because you know
the whole marijuana thing and the
commission's in Texas yeah Commission in
Texas you can't smoke yeah so you had
posted yeah here's my thing Jake Paul
very smart guy team around him very
smart nobody considered this month ago
nobody
you know Nate Diaz is Mr Weed yeah he's
mr420 Mr 209 Mr 420. Nobody considered
nobody out of your staff of 10 guys
nobody thought to look into the
marijuana testing in Texas commission
there must be a way around it but uh so
he posted way around is by moving States
so he posted this on the second and
today he just posted this it's still in
Dallas so interesting I wonder like if
you let's say they've he did marijuana
got caught he could still fight right
he's getting like a punishment or
something
uh
um yeah it depends
yeah it really depends I don't know how
strict they're gonna be there
um
he could and they give him a fine
but I wonder if it nullifies the win
which I guess doesn't really matter yeah
and then also I assume if they or Jake
might be like listen we can't switch
venues it's too late just do it and
we're gonna cover the fine and pay you
extra don't back out or don't make us
move it because we'll lose money
and I wonder if Texas like kind of
turned their heads on it because that's
muddy for them as well you know for sure
they have enough money there but yeah
for sure
hope you guys are enjoying the show last
break of the show this episode of the
shop show breakdown UFC 289 we have a
calabas fight campaign 7 P.M Pacific
live on thick boy YouTube this Saturday
for UFC 289 you got the schmoe Paulie
Shore and a very special guest so make
sure you tune in it will be more
exciting than the card let's be honest
but this episode of the shop show is
brought to you by on it the one in true
the Trident we're talking about on it
we're talking about Alpha Brain the
number one nootropic on the freaking
planet they sold over a million bottles
here's the kicker too if you don't love
Alpha Brain you don't feel it it's not
getting you that Jeff Bezos level you
can send you don't have to send the
product back keep your money they refund
your money give it to somebody who's
gonna appreciate it all right but you're
gonna love it they've sold over a
million bottles it's the best nootropic
in the freaking planet it helps you AIDS
mental processing it's caffeine free
helps with the flow State promotes Focus
supports memory remember names places
Fighters all their old fight cards one
of the fights they were on helps with
all that focus on complex tasks think
more clearly under stress react more
quickly we can all use this they have
Alpha Brain regular which everybody
knows about the silver million bottles
they have Alpha Brain Black Alpha Brain
instant the Alpha Brain shot I prefer
the Alpha Brain Black it's like Alpha
Brain on steroids it's fantastic on it
also offers fitness equipment like
kettlebell steel Club Macy's sandbags
yoga mats need better nutrition say less
thick Boy Summer they have protein
powders creatine mc2l multivitamins we
got it all it's the One Stop Shop to get
your thick ass in shape this summer and
also to get your brain right with the
best neutral book on the planet talking
about Alpha Brain try the Alpha Brain
Black you won't regret it go to
audit.com you get 10 off you're welcome
let's get back to the program alrighty
so I was gonna
oh let's just talk about this real quick
because this was from um this past fight
Jerry Gordon was was supposed to fight
Jim Miller and then like a day or two
before he got pulled because during the
media day he announced that he had a
concussion from that Bobby the Bobby
green fight when they hit heads and then
he's like but I cured it on my on my own
somehow or something like that as soon
as you say concussion
it was only six weeks yeah they pulled
them and Daniel Danny got pissed off
that like why would you yeah why would
you say like you got a concussion you
healed it yourself like you're not a
doctor
but my question for Dana so there's the
commission you have to go through all
that before you fight there's coaches
like there's tons of levels you have to
go through before it got to this point
so you shouldn't be bad at Jared Gordon
you know
um I mean there's a lot of other people
that are responsible for this Fighter's
gonna fight I mean he it just him openly
admitting it if that's the problem but
how long ago did he get headbutt by six
weeks and then where's the commission
exactly why is there a six-month
suspension he didn't get concussion or
they they might have like said he didn't
yeah is that on Jared Gordon you're
right you know Dan is right he's not a
[__] doctor yeah
so the doctors at the fight where he got
headbutted by Bobby green
during the commission game was six month
suspension
if they deemed a concussion he should
say the commission [__] up this
kitchen never been on this card in the
first place Jerry Goring in a fight his
bills to pay it's in a Jared Gordon
fighter issue this is Dana White's the
the way they get guys to get into the
Octagon the the process there's a whole
process meant and somewhere he was able
to slip through the process that's on
you Amigo that's not Jared Gordon that's
on you and your staff to me being a
Jared Gordon that's on you [__]
you're the one that let him slip through
the cracks then we get a fight he's like
I'm still concussed but I guess they say
I'm good you're not a [__] doctor I
know but they said I was good I'm not
good I should have a six-month
suspension they always give six more
suspensions who the [__] thought he was
okay how does his team go yeah dude just
got knocked out six weeks ago but I
think you're good okay
stop way before this Fighter's gonna
fight dude that's why they're [__]
Fighters and like how could they do with
TJ Jill show I can't believe you fought
with one shoulder Fighter's gonna fight
Fire's gonna fight
it should have been stopped way before
this don't be mad TJ don't be mad Jared
Gordon be mad at the procedures in place
that allows these guys to even sign up
to take the fight
because if I'm Dana it's my business
and they go hey Jared going Jim Miller
damn that's a great fight hey have
someone go check out Jerry going though
he just got knocked out six months six
weeks ago are we sure he's good before
but marketing all the [__] into it
I agree
Fighter's gonna fight
I can't believe they don't consider that
concussion too because it's stopped
inside for it insane all this is he
didn't it's all good just take a little
accountability that's on me that kitchen
never been on the card he got knocked
out six weeks ago I can't believe Sean
Shelby whoever the mick Maynard all the
guys that Commissioned I can't believe
they thought he was gonna be good to
fight that's on us Jerry Gordon should
never been on this card that's how
that's called doing grown man [__]
taking accountability Ah that's on me
yeah we [__] up he's out Southern
guy's in Jared needs to take some time
rest not be con concussed so he's a long
career take some accountability
fair enough
uh so Matt Brown has been beefing with
Conor McGregor lately and the most
recent thing was I've watched him fight
yeah
um
this is Matt on I think it was up on a
podcast talking about Conor McGregor
Conor McGregor so he put uh this is Matt
Brown speaking not me but everything you
see is him drinking or getting coked up
or you know he's Juiced out of his mind
that's effing bum life to me all that
money don't make you a not a bum when
you step in the cage you're effing bum
after learning about those comments this
is a funny commentary without he's such
a Savage tweet out Matt Brown heroin
addict this is so funny he's undefeated
when it comes to stuff kind of Fanboys
are basically same demographics as Miley
fans at least Connor was once a great
Champion with a crazy high ceiling bring
on the hate
Boozies he does give him compliments
about who he was in the past another
person who gives confidence about
Conor's past is true Jordan True Jordy
that's our boy I love true Jordi and
then so he I here's a video showing
Connor like you know just fumbling on
his words and looking like he might be
drunk or on coke and then he was saying
something's wrong with Conor now and
then Connor obviously heard about it
yeah you gotta be careful I I think the
problem
here too is you know true Jordi
obviously he's in the same business as I
am you know Connor whenever you
mentioned Connor good or bad it gets
views right you know Connor's good for
business
but I think he did a few videos on
[__] on Connor and he's at a level
where he gets to Connor meaning he sees
it or his team sees it and then Tyler's
gonna be careful what you asked for he's
gonna fire back it's very rare he loses
these things and he there's no there's
no boundaries so you got to be careful
with this stuff I don't recommend doing
it you know true Jordan's a grown man
he's up we're obviously talking about it
so that's what he wanted that's what he
got I don't like it I love you Jordy and
I love Connor you guys know how much I
love Connor true Jordy is a buddy of
mine we talk he's a great dude
um
OV it stops here you know because I
think he even went on a personal level
which I don't like
oh yeah you can play The Voice okay yeah
so Connor's been doing these voice notes
I don't think he's like one of the only
guys that does this right I don't
remember people doing this before but
anyways it's the Twitter voice note
victim looking thing [__] me my new
skull that you would have killed your
fat [__] you're fat nobody you're a
little feminine [__] of a thing
keep my name out of your mouth just
stupid
in your fat porn face Scully fat
estrogen head
oh my God you have to understand what
I'm saying
you've got subtitles under the [__]
thing saying exactly what I'm saying so
what are you saying you're looking for
No Name Mr Easter yeah he's messed up
but I don't want these problems dude
there's no need for it there's no need
for it you don't want these problems you
know Connor has time you know it's time
the alarming this a lot all that I don't
like any of that stuff you know I don't
like like the drama [__] but I love both
those guys but the the bummer where I
was alarmed is dating the press
conference goes
they're actually they asked about the
Conor uh Chandler fight he goes you know
it's tough to get these guys to fight
you know you look at the money could be
made and then he retires it's tough when
you're making that much money you have
that much money in the bank to fight in
a you know in a steel cage it's just I
get it and I was like wait what
oh this fight's not happening
you know like he was in like you know
Connor she has love for the game and
we're gonna come out with announcement
he's like get stuff man I mean hell yeah
it's tough and then people like well
look at look at Tom Brady and look at
the money he made and you know look at
Michael Jordan and Kobe Bryant these
guys that have all this money keep
playing yeah yeah notice I said playing
they're not fighting there's no off
season it's it's the toughest
professional gig in the world when it
comes to sports there's nothing harder
than being a professional fighter at the
highest level it is exhausting so yeah
yeah dude yeah and good for them khabib
Conor you get all that money yeah it's
tough to it's tough to get in there when
you don't have to
that's why when I heard Dana said I'm
like
oh the fight's not happening we're not
going to see Connor fine are we he even
referenced like go when George left
George Saint Pierre and Anderson Silva
we always have a big roster it's going
to be replaced when people say it's over
and yeah there's always somebody next
like wait what you know it's like what
are you talking about where is this
energy for The Ultimate Fighter you're
like we're good enough to fight we're
just not telling you when it's like
oh I see what's going on here you're
Honey dick in it so we tune into the
ultimate fighter and then we never get
the fight how dare you but also I'll
watch
I'll watch Ultimate Fighter in hopes
they fight but they're definitely not
going to yeah that's why I and I was
like guaranteeing they were gonna fight
now it's like oh no no he's setting us
up here he knows that yeah
that's a bummer yeah it is
um how many times hope he kind of does
it you know but it doesn't sound like it
come from and also good for you as much
as I love Connor he's good for business
and I you know we've never seen anybody
like him if Conor's like you know what
y'all nah this is stupid how about that
how about I have 300 million in the bank
I get a yacht I'm playing grab ass the
death one I'm doing my thing I got my
shirt open how about I'm just gonna keep
doing this he owes you nothing he owes
Dana and UFC nothing he's given them
everything
I don't know why like I would love for
kind of come back favorite fighter if he
doesn't
I I'm all about it dude it could be when
he obviously went for different reasons
good for you man when these guys retire
they still have their wits about them
and they got all the money in the bank
that's what we want here guys you don't
want Conor sticking around till he's
face down ass up and he's concussed his
[__] a BJ Penn a Diego Sanchez we don't
want how sad is that stuff Tony Ferguson
we do not want this guys we should
celebrate when a guy goes Mom good man
let me get on my Lamborghini yacht and
travel the world with my family
yeah hell yeah good for you dude you won
so it's all I'd be happy if he does good
for him dude good for him yeah it sucks
worse with fans you mean case love him
but
it'd be dope if if he already came out I
was like you know what [__] this game
I'm gonna sit on Sidelines talk [__] on
my yacht
keep making businesses good for you do
you have the option damn that's dope
it's not a negative thing yeah I mean it
sucks for Chandler but then Chandler did
you get to do Ultimate Fighter so he's
more exposed to people too so it's and
there's there's five that 55 that are
fire this fight's at 70 for channel
they're fire fire fights
Chandler der you should sick
they want to do if they're like Darius
you got to win a 10th fight there's just
one more I can see that happen it's
Chandler you do a 10th fight he's all
white yeah
tell me if I've already brought this up
I don't remember if I did Adam Sandler
and the UFC they're working together for
a comedy Oh weird I don't get a discount
needs to find New York city so you think
he's gonna call
laughs
it's like an office they said like a UFC
office show you know the office is great
so it's supposed to be that kind of that
kind of feel yeah yeah
they're gonna get the same writers that
wrote the office I mean I don't see how
much [__] phenomenal so he's one of
my favorites but this is not my alley at
all this is insane can you imagine if
this guy did comedy then I'll see sweat
and UFC they'll be insane
sounds like you'd be a perfect pitch for
the show oh and the guy who's favorite
person on Earth that I'm saying this is
weird dude where are you gonna find that
guy that's in I know I don't know
alrighty
um so
I just want to show you these because
this is insane this is from ma fighting
dude that knockout from the bottom of
Mount yes I mean these are all finished
I won't turn the audio on so that's yeah
knocking someone out cold from the
bottom
you you know what's crazy about this
you're talking about that's an arena out
there 55 000 people whoa hacked and this
is crazy too oh god dog yeah it looks
like they put a hell of event yeah why
does the ref have all these sponsors all
over him
let's see
ksw you don't realize how big it is
Poland or something yeah I think so he
was pulling dude 55 000 people there
look at that packed they're all into it
like crazy too look at the reference
yeah he's got a lot of stuff on them
Boop
pink that dude got knocked out from the
bottom amount that hey it's embarrassing
B you got to be so jacked up to not to
do it out from the mount
and this is Marius pujanowski and they
were throwing yeah
see you know he's had a great career for
a guy that went from strong man to into
fighting first MMA is kind of a freak
it's like a circus show yeah dude must
want it you know she'd be scrapping
oh so
here keto George wanted me to show you
this and get your opinion on it uh-huh
wait not that
this is marab at the last event wait bro
bro shirt too tight I know he's saying
that those two buttons are hanging on
for dear life
those two buttons are hanging on like
Charles delivers [__] carrying this
card this weekend it is taking
everything in this hour not to bust and
his I guess his hair it looks like he
has plugs or something the turkey hell
yeah dog
that shirt is God bless the who let me
know what shirt that is because it's
quality that thing that busting his tits
pop out this shirt is quality
I've been there though it looks good on
the arms you're like man here's the move
uh marab what you got to do is just
leave it on button dude
I have a Dodgers jersey I tighten that
thing up my I have double D's I have
solid Double D's if I tighten that thing
up let's push her underneath dude wear a
tank top
so get the arms popping but if the
buttons aren't [__] struggle City
like [__] lizzo Skechers you know
what I'm saying
maybe he actually likes that style I
don't know hey but no yeah it doesn't
look good on anybody the the problem the
first ones the first one is struggle
cities are like that guy's in shape when
the second third and fourth like dude
dude the levee's gonna break here you
gotta unbutton it
the girl in the back seems like it
though so that's all that matters
on her she's hot yeah she's cool
alrighty um that's pretty much it it's
so tight yeah you should have spray
painted on that's cool
uh there you have it yeah UFC 289 this
weekend again not gonna knock your dick
in the ground but it is a fun card I'll
tell you I can guarantee you the cow
basketball campaign is gonna be way
better we got Paulie Shore we got some
we got the Schmo coming and another
giant guest it's gonna be a grand old
time the tiger thick whiskey is going to
be flowing the [__] it's gonna be fun
get into it I'm looking forward to it uh
Charles Oliveira garyush let's not
pretend that's not the main event can we
all knock the [__] off all right all
right change can you knock the [__] off
man that is you got a Mexican probably
can be your uh women's bantamweight
champ so that's cool yeah Danny he on
the car against Nate landware which is
always fun but again is it worth 80
that's up to you calabas fight campaign
it's free it's gonna be better than this
so tune in 7 P.M Pacific on thick boy
YouTube only like And subscribe to the
channel right now if you haven't done
that love you guys thanks for watching
I'll be doing spots all around La in the
summer going to spend time with my
family so I love you guys next tour date
on the books right now there will be
more but right now it's Spokane
Washington Spokane is September 21st the
23rd I'm at skank Fest in Las Vegas
that's right it's gankfest Las Vegas
September 29th through October 1st get
you some all right then I have Chet
Niagara Falls New York Niagara Falls New
York's November 4th and 5th I think one
show on the fourth one show on the fifth
some big ass Casino in Niagara Falls New
York never been there I'll check out the
fall for 10 seconds and move about my
day all right and I just refreshed this
shop and Friends Pasadena holy [__]
that's news to me too shopping friends
in Pasadena Ice House July 28th one show
only probably 8pm show get you some so
we got Pasadena coming up in July at
Spokane skank Fest Niagara Falls
there'll be a lot more dates coming soon
I'll have some news for you guys all
right love you guys enjoy the fights
this weekend you'll see 289 tune in to
Calabasas fight campaign Live on YouTube
the Shmo Paulie Shore a big ass special
guest myself that's live on but 7 PM
Pacific on thick boy YouTube only love
you guys like subscribe do all the
things people tell you to do love you
see you next time